the shadow is a moral problem that
challenges the whole ego personality for
no one can become conscious of the
Shadow Without considerable moral effort
to become conscious of it involves
recognizing the dark aspects of the
personality as present and real this act
is the essential condition for any kind
of self-knowledge
the idea of the Shadow Self was first
conceived by Carl Jung probably the most
important psychologist of the previous
century Jung described the shadow as an
unconscious aspect of ourselves formed
from our suppressed desires ideas and
instincts a cognitive blind spot in our
psyche until you make the unconscious
conscious it will direct your life and
you will call it fate
the use of the word Shadow wasn't chosen
unintentionally
Jung was always good at portraying
complex ideas in a proper visual manner
he used mental images in order to create
associations with Concepts already
familiar to the human mind the shadow is
dark and Elusive it is impossible to
catch its size can change depending on
your position in space and it is always
there whenever light is present so one
can form a somewhat basic understanding
of the concept without the need to delve
into complex terms another crucial thing
to take into account is that the Sado
itself due to the darkness that it forms
and due to the distance that it creates
from the physical body of a person
becomes something people don't really
want to confront
and this is one of the major ideas
associated with the jungian shadow
although we usually see the shadow as an
important part of our existence most of
us are blind to this existence we can't
control what we can't see so the work is
a relatively new age concept and refers
to the process of assimilating the
shadow that is attempting to dive into
the unconscious parts of our psyche and
trying to internalize them and make
peace with them assimilation is a
lengthy process that demands mainly
psychotherapy but also hours of
introspection and constant reevaluation
and recalibration of personal behaviors
and beliefs Shadow work is challenging
therefore when trying to assimilate the
shadow we need to ask ourselves some
challenging questions
most of you have heard of the story of
Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde the famous idiom
is inspired by the book Strange Case of
Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde written by the
Scottish author Robert Lewis Stevenson
in 1886. in it he describes the life of
a man who transforms between two
personni Dr Henry Jekyll and Mr Edward
Hyde
the story was so powerful and it
resonated with so many people that it
entered the vernacular and whenever we
encounter characters with an
unpredictably dual nature we almost
immediately refer to them as Jekyll and
Hyde most of us can cite events from our
lives where our actions and our intent
didn't really align we behaved as if we
were different people this is because of
our persona persona is the image that we
project to the world according to Jung
the Persona is a complicated system of
relations between individual
Consciousness and Society fittingly
enough a kind of mask designed on the
one hand to make a definite impression
upon others and on the other to conceal
the true nature of the individual our
dark side is concealed or camouflaged in
a painful attempt to protect our Persona
the image that we adopt in order to fit
in through social conditioning we come
to construct a facade that keeps the
substrate of our identity stable so that
we can keep feeling safe
safety however is ill-defined in that
space we inhabit how can we feel safe
when we're constantly sacrificing our
true self for our Persona our Persona
controls the way we project who we are
and how we interact with the world a
great example of this is social media
this is the online manifestation of our
Persona the problem is that we are much
more than the image we project to the
world constantly neglecting the true
self for the Persona can cause internal
instability and the shadow will take
over
Shadow work allows us to see beyond the
Persona and try to escape from it when
we see that it tyrannizes our lives
most of life is struggle we badly
struggle with Clarity in order to
clarify something you need to understand
its mechanics maybe something isn't
working well because a part that
comprises the whole is actually
malfunctioning when we break down the
hole in parts and carefully examine
these parts we can discover details
about systems that are usually unknown
then we can go back to the system itself
and look at how what we discovered can
improve the performance of the system as
a whole Clarity manifests itself in that
way when you allow the part to discover
all its nuances and all its capabilities
you end up with a reinforced version of
it that can offer more to the whole
humans operate that way and the dawn of
the internet made that idea more Vivid
we experience a collective Awakening
that can perhaps lead to a collective
Enlightenment information becomes widely
accessible and we can improve our error
correcting mechanisms just by asking and
Gathering as many views as possible that
right there is the essence of clarity
and its only obstacle is the shadow our
Collective Shadow is pushing us towards
ignorance and ignorance reinforces our
struggle a person who clings to outdated
and age-defined Views will only
reinforce the Shadow and lose themselves
in a swamp of confusion incessant
knowledge seeking is the name of the
game a game we should all prepare to
play
dreams serve as a direct conduit to our
subconscious mind where the shadow
resides they offer us a symbolic
language through which our innermost
thoughts feelings and conflicts can
Surface by paying attention to our
dreams we can gain valuable insights
into the workings of our psyche and the
aspects of ourselves we need to address
a common practice we can follow is dream
journaling by recording our dreams we
can identify patterns that repeat
themselves as we accumulate the entries
in our Dream Journal we can look for
recurring themes symbols and emotions
often the shadow is represented in
Dreams by characters or situations that
evoke fear discomfort or unease
these elements May point to aspects of
ourselves that we have been neglecting
or suppressing once we identify
potential Shadow elements in our dreams
we can engage in self-reflection we can
discuss with our therapists what these
symbols or emotions mean to us
personally we can analyze how they
relate to our Waking Life and whether
they resonate with any repressed
feelings or desires we might have
regardless of how hard you try and
regardless of how much self-awareness
you accrue over the years dark moments
are inevitable
especially if you are a creative and
sensitive person your proclivity towards
darkness is going to affect your world
in an intense way once you recognize
that the Moment of Truth begins when you
stare at the darkness the darkness
stares back at you it is a momentous
instance in your life you either allow
it to own you or you fight back there is
no middle ground there the darkness has
many forms it can have the form of a
shadow as young put it it can have the
form of mental and physical pain it can
have the form of depression and a
general disconnection from reality all
these forms signify that one has let
oneself go and surrendered to a dark
reality that was imposed on them one way
or the other a dark reality usually
signals a lack of purpose and an astute
lack of discipline throughout the Daily
Grind whether we like it or not we are
purpose-driven beings purpose is what
allows us to add more structure to our
lives and eventually have control over
it purpose can manifest itself in many
ways it can be an obsession with arts in
an attempt to satisfy the need for
self-expression it can be the ambition
to change the world for the better it
can be whatever the individual decides
it to be once you identify your purpose
leave it wholeheartedly create systems
processes goals and protocols around it
find other actors who have similar
purposes engage with them escape the
bonality of abstract living that is
defined by others and assemble your life
around your purpose do that in a
discipline and if the circumstance
demands it obsessed way that's how you
overcome Darkness
[Music]